animación
[Música]
música interna
hola bienvenidos una vez más a esta
emisión de canadá en las américas café
el programa semanal que les proponemos
desde el servicio en español de radio
canadá internacional en esta ocasión en
una emisión especial estamos una vez más
fuera de nuestro estudio hoy presentes
en la zona de confort sí señor hoy
presentes en la nueva edición del salón
de la inmigración que se lleva a cabo en
el palacio de los congresos en pleno
centro de la ciudad de montreal mi
nombre es luis laborda y conmigo va a
estar hoy como coanimador pablo gómez
barrio bienvenido pablo una vez más
gracias luis y vos para lo tienes
algunos datos sobre este salón de la
inmigración hacia el louis esta es la
octava edición del salón de la
inmigración y de la integración más de
quebec bueno la idea es que haya hay más
de 200
kioscos más de 200 profesionales que
están aquí presentes en el salón para
ofrecer su ayuda sus servicios de una
forma gratuita claro está para todas las
personas que vengan a visitar y todo
relacionado con la inmigración planeta
así que
va a haber conferencias y va a haber
talleres hay 45 talleres y 45
conferencias y para no extenderme
demasiado entre los talleres hay uno en
particular que me llamo que me llamó la
atención y se llama la dra que en quebec
es para los que en español y para los
que nos están escuchando allá del otro
lado del micrófono seguiría como
enamorar en quebec no bueno pues están
haciendo estamos ofreciendo un taller de
esos aquí porque entonces la temática es
variada es integración en el más amplio
sentido del término y tenemos por
supuesto invitados que forman parte de
los expositores de los numerosos
expositores que están presentes aquí en
este salón que ustedes irán viendo en
imágenes que les mostrará nuestra cámara
móvil a lo largo de nuestra emisión de
hoy a mi derecha inmediatamente está
milena cortez lópez que es del centro de
juventud y empleo nicolette ya más acá
con ella vamos a estar hablando
es nada más al costado de pablo está jon
hermina del servicio de recepción de los
recién llegados más así tenemos analiza
tu seña para ti que es de futur prender
con quien vamos a hablar de los
emprendedores y de las facilidades que
hay para los emprendedores aquí en
canadá y en quebec en particular también
estará gabriel garcía del centro para la
inmigración en región una problemática
que nos preocupa a todos saber cómo
hacer para llevar a los inmigrantes a
las distintas regiones de la provincia y
no solamente para las grandes ciudades y
retenerlos además allí y también está en
la punta de la mesa analuisa iturriaga
que es de fórum 2020 con quien vamos a
hablar específicamente de la
problemática de la mujer referida a la
inmigración y luego se sumará ricardo
acevedo que es coordinador de
operaciones del sitio calificaciones que
ve que nos va a hablar un poco de cómo
es el proceso de reconocimiento de
calificaciones de estudio y de títulos
que pueden llevar a cabo los inmigrantes
uno de los temas que más preocupa a
quienes llegan aquí y para comenzar
ese es uno de los temas que más
provocado dificultades en los
inmigrantes aquí en este país el
reconocimiento de los diplomas señor
llega a la gente diplomada y les lleva
una eternidad
[Música]
le reconozcan sus diplomas ya de hecho
hay que hacer un esfuerzo enorme por
aprender el idioma a controlar el idioma
y después cuando lo tienes el
reconocimiento del de los diplomas que
puede ser tarda mucho y para comenzar a
hablar con nuestros invitados comenzamos
entonces con milena cortez lópez del
centro juventud y empleo ni colecta ya
más caminen a puedes el trabajo que
lleva a cabo este centro bueno yo
trabajo por carrefour ciones amplo a que
es para tener es como con la mercè de mi
colegio a más cara y la idea de nosotros
es como representar la región y
promocionar nuestra región la idea es
que los inmigrantes que llegan a
montreal
conozcan y vean la realidad de otras
regiones que hay oportunidades de
trabajo que a veces es más económico y
es mucho más fácil a veces la
integración versión que se llama centro
juventud y empleo de la clientela de
ustedes solamente jóvenes de la ciudad
entre 16 y 35 años pero el proyecto en
el que yo soy a cargo es con el
ministerio de inmigración y de inclusión
nosotros trabajamos no importa la edad
perfecto y pablo
a mi lado a mi diestra tengo a iones
iones mina él
trabaja con el servicio de acogida de
recién llegados bienvenidos gracias muy
amable y explícanos un poco el trabajo
el servicio de acogida de inmigrantes su
nombre lo dice pero qué hacen ustedes en
este campo el mismo nombre lo dice hace
13 años estamos funcionando con algo que
la misma comunidad creó y fue ese
servicio que era una necesidad que el
medio veía para poderlos indudablemente
incluir e integrarlos que sean útiles y
eso lo que nosotros hacemos que lo que
hacemos cada día hacemos acciones para
indudablemente buscarle solución a cada
pequeño detalle de integración empujamos
eso lo que hacemos empujamos las
personas para que avancen en sus
objetivos o las cuales llegaron aquí y
la organización está basada en donde en
louisville
tenemos la región del amor y si dan
nuestros territorios la de mercedes
mckinnon ya es un territorio es la
puerta a la entrada de la región de la
música está bien la capital esto la
rivière por así decirlo y nosotros
estamos a louisville en nuestra capital
louisville que representa a la de merece
demasiado y cuántos inmigrantes más o
menos digo con cuántos inmigrantes
cuenta la comunidad mil más o menos mil
más o menos ahora tenemos mil hace trece
años los colombianos y colombianos la
mayoría vamos a seguir hablando luego
con horner pero también tenemos de
invitada analista tu señor para ti que
es de futuro prender canadá que es
futuro pender canadá analista bueno
entonces sorprenderlo quesería
canadá es un organismo sin fines de
lucro
si usted es de hace 22 años y trabajamos
en todo
y bueno también trabajamos en la
provincia entera de quebec con entre
emprendedores quienes tienen entre 18 y
39 años de edad entonces lo que
ofrecemos es financiamiento hasta 45 mil
dólares
este coaching entonces un mentor
para emprendedores quienes están
lanzando su empresa muy bien vamos a
seguir más tarde conociendo más detalles
entonces de este proceso de
financiamiento de los emprendedores
pablo tú tienes además a gabriel garcía
invitado también así de gabriel garcía
en mexico bienvenido a gabriel iván a
muchísimas gracias por la invitación y
bueno nosotros estamos representando el
centro para la inmigración
hacemos un organismo sin fines de lucro
que tenemos un poco de haber empezado
gracia
gracias por la invitación y bueno
nosotros nos dimos la tarea de promover
la región de ashanti porque bueno en ese
momento cuando yo me instaló en la
variante de hace 6 años me doy cuenta
que era casi el único inmigrante que
estaba por allá para situar a la gente
que nos están escuchando y claro que ahí
está
pues pertenece a la región de bas
logan's y aunque sólo son los cantiles
entonces estamos hablando que sea una
hora de camino de montreal entonces son
todas aquellas pequeñas regiones que
están muy cerca de montreal y que
desafortunadamente no se les ha dado el
auge y las oportunidades que pueden
representar para muchas familias
personas inmigrantes
entonces como como les decía retomando
mi historia yo me estables con esa
región y me doy cuenta que no existían
los servicios para los inmigrantes
porque cuando de hecho éramos muy pocos
entonces dije bueno por qué no lanzar
una organización que va a promover esta
región y también nos dimos cuenta que la
región era muy agrícola entonces también
decidimos de tomar esa misión que es un
poco también
un gran desafío de construir una
clase d
en emprendedores inmigrantes en la
agricultura no únicamente que nos vean
como mano de obra
en el campo pero también como
administradores de las empresas
agrícolas iniciativas exactamente
y por último tenemos a ana luisa
iturriaga que ella es integrante de
forum 2020 corrector general que es una
iniciativa local de la población y de
los políticos de sant ya sean ms de más
que está bonita estamos a una hora de
montreal también pero yendo hacia quebec
por la ribera sur y es una región con
mucho auge en todo lo que se profesional
para los profesionistas e igualmente
también a nivel de lanzar empresas
tenemos gente que ha logrado tenemos
sexto lugar en quebec y doceavo en todo
canadá entonces tenemos ejemplos de
colombianos y bastantes personas que han
logrado poner su empresa en informática
en limpia limpieza en sanidad es
restaurantes o sea somos una región
dinámica y que está esperando que la
gente venga y ahorita actualmente
muchísimos muchísimos latinoamericanos
entonces cómo queda ya visto en la
presentación de todos nuestros invitados
pablo la inmigración
no solamente importa los grandes centros
urbanos sino que es un tema de las
regiones también y ese es uno de los
temas más importantes con los embates se
debate perdón inmigración en estos
momentos es sacar a la gente de las
grandes ciudades donde a veces las
posibilidades son menos de las que se
cree y llevarlas a las regiones que
necesitan mano de obra
necesitan emprendedores necesitan gente
de talento y necesitan ocupar puestos
laborales que muchas veces permanecen
sin la gente que los desempeñe
y es fuerza de trabajo que se pierde
para adentrarnos ya un poco más en los
detalles aunque pablo creo que
nacionalidad es decir justamente que de
hecho los invitados que están alrededor
de esta mesa son todos de regiones en
los que como tú bien lo decías con los
desafíos son distintos que los que puede
haber en los grandes centros urbanos
exacto mire nada hablando de juventud
pues son los principales desafíos que
enfrentan los jóvenes inmigrantes para
integrarse laboralmente o en términos
generales para su nueva sociedad según
tu experiencia según lo que ustedes ven
así
si hablamos de pequeños de niños
pequeños pues tenemos también la
necesidad de un colegio de colegios de
acogida necesitamos que los niños los
adolescentes estén más hayan más
actividades para implicarlos en la
sociedad por eso es que creamos
actividades creamos en recursos para que
se metan en el lugar exacto para que
ellos puedan participar para que se
impliquen es un desafío realmente no
importa que no importa qué inmigrante
que llegue es un desafío para un adulto
es un desafío para un adolescente para
un niño yo creo que el hecho de que
nosotros somos inmigrantes y ya vivimos
esa situación
nos da una credibilidad entre nosotros
nosotros inmigrantes que invitamos
nuestra región de la mercè de mask y de
nicolás ya más acá
yo hablo porque monex patrones aquí
presentes
yo trabajé para el sana un año también
tengo veo las necesidades que se crean
en región y que son importantes para que
los niños las personas se integren la
transición es importante
una familia nosotros no sólo pensamos en
la parte laboral hay que pensar en que
viene una familia completa y que tenemos
que ver las necesidades de la mujer
también de la esposa de las necesidades
a nivel laboral tenemos muchísimas
ofertas de empleo que son calificadas
como usted viene de decir hay trabajos
especializados si no se encuentra la
mano de obra y hay más posibilidades por
un inmigrante en región efectivamente
hay más facilidad
son menos las personas que se postulan
vamos a entonces se desarrollan más
detalles en esa problemática pablo y
bueno yo no me decía es ahorita que hay
alrededor de unos mil inmigrantes en la
región evidentemente estamos haciendo
nosotros somos el servicio
latinoamericano de radio canadá
internacional estamos todos acá en
español pero estos servicios se ofrecen
a todos los inmigrantes que
habitan que viven en ese lugar el que
nacionalidades de inmigrantes en grandes
líneas viven en tu región a ver
es muy importante la pregunta esas mil
personas que están establecidas allá
permanentemente durablemente representan
50 nacionalidades 5 y 50 nacionalidades
y se habla 38 lenguas hemos hecho un
repertorio de eso y yo diría que hay un
equilibrio de sambil están repartidos
más que todo entre latinos y africanos
siguen grande escala si hay granito de
cada nacionalidad pero en grande escala
más que todos son africanos
latinos y también europeos
indudablemente este es un lugar es una
torre de babel prácticamente
indudablemente en como todo el mundo
habla francés que ese es el objeto todo
el mundo habla francés tenemos la
fragilización para los que no hablan
para los alumnos que no hablan
inicialmente tenemos la gran sensación
el medio está allí trabajamos muy
mancomunadamente con el medio es tanto
que la palabra inmigrante no existe
ahora quedó abolida completamente
prohibido cometimos que venimos de
aprobar la política de acogida y de
retención de nuevos arribantes y quedó
prohibido que se diga inmigrante mejor
por parís precisamente por eliminar
muchas barreras
vamos a continuar después con este tema
luis porque parece quedar grande
hablábamos de emprendedores no todo el
que llega a canadá
a emplearse como vapor bajo relación de
dependencia en todo caso hay mucha gente
que tiene ideas que tiene proyectos que
quiere iniciar su propio emprendimiento
su propia empresa su propio negocio
quien esté interesado en ello quien
tenga esa idea en la cabeza incluso
antes de llegar a canadá una vez
arribado aquí qué pasos debe seguir con
quién se puede contactar qué es lo que
debe hacer para poner en marcha su
proyecto bueno entonces ahí cuando hay
emprendedores llegando a canadá hay un
ecosistema muy grande entonces claro hay
bastante recursos
en nuestro caso bueno bastante recursos
y para por ejemplo
apoyar a hacer un plan de negocio que es
que la mayoría de las veces si si
alguien quiere este financiamiento hay
que hacerlo no el plan de negocio sin
flujo de caja también entonces hay bueno
hay un acompañamiento para eso y también
para bueno prepararse hacer no
emprendedor a lanzar su empresa entonces
eso es algo que
futuro no lo hace
y también bueno otros actores y algunos
están aquí en el salón también y bueno
un bueno algo importante en nuestro
programa es que para hacer bueno para
pedir financiamiento
hay que ser éste
residente permanente entonces claro eso
puede demorar un poco pero una vez que
ya una persona es residente permanente
si puede la aclaración vale porque
muchas veces la gente piensa que tiene
la mala idea de que no hay ciertas cosas
que no se pueden hacer hasta que uno es
ciudadano en realidad con la residencia
permanente que es lo que obtiene la
mayoría de los que llegan aquí como
inmigrantes los refugiados es otro tema
pero como inmigrante se llega siempre
con la residencia permanente
ese estatus es suficiente como para
poder pretender iniciar un
emprendimiento propio y pedir
financiamiento y en nuestro caso de
hecho tenemos un programa especial para
los
recién llegados entonces si es posible
perfecto pablo gabriel tú
ya no existe la misma diversidad que hay
por ejemplo acá nos hablaba yo nerd de
50 nacionalidades más o menos la misma
pregunta qué tipo de nacionalidades hay
en tu región pues sí claro entonces qué
bueno que también nos dieron la
oportunidad de participar a esta mesa
porque bueno como decíamos anteriormente
son diferentes realidades de cada región
tiene sus desafíos y bueno nosotros
estamos empezando a desde abajo no
obviamente como decía nuestro organismo
nace de la necesidad de como yo como
individuo que no me sentí como si
podríamos decir desamparado y que no
había como los servicios no que entonces
dije bueno yo voy a ofrecer los
servicios pero a quién se los ofrezco
porque me los voy a ofrecer a mí mismo
al final por eso dijimos bueno no nos
damos como misión
de construir ese multiculturalismo que
le hace falta a la región que
identificamos y que fuimos a presentar
un proyecto a nuestra merced
y qué bueno que nos apoyaron y nos
dijeron es cierto nos falta
tal vez es no en este momento porque las
oportunidades de empleo empiezan a
presentarse pero bueno hay que construir
todo eso no es una vez realmente otra
realidad en comparación a las otras
regiones que ya que están aquí en la
mesa y que escucho por decir ya de sant
se acerque que hay muchas muchas
oportunidades de empleo en muchas
oportunidades también desde impartir en
empresa y todo eso y nosotros en nuestra
realidad navegante ahí es como en la
presentación se vio cuando yo dije vengo
de adelante hoy donde está eso no
entonces bueno ese es el desafío en lo
primero ponerlo en el mapa después
decirle a la gente venga para acá que
desde aquí hay estas oportunidades de
empleo y bueno el desafío es también de
después
y hacer los que se queden porque al
final las las ofertas de empleo están
ahí pero bueno es como otra realidad no
las las ofertas que nosotros tenemos ahí
es como a nivel obrero como no puestos
muy calificados entonces son como otra
realidad también otro desafío que
tenemos es que en la región no tenemos
una escuela post secundaria
no está el celler el más próximo es en
salieron el transporte en común no está
desarrollado estamos hablando de una
zona semirural entonces dependemos al
cien por ciento del automóvil la emerse
empieza a tener un cierto servicio de
transporte pero bueno no es como como la
gente está acostumbrada a tenerla en
otras ciudades entonces bueno estas son
realmente desafíos con lo que nos vemos
confrontados y con lo que hay que
construir precisamente esa
multiculturalidad no entonces estamos en
otra realidad muy distinta no perfecto
analiza analizada iturriaga no todo el
que llega a canadá llegan las mismas
condiciones y con las mismas necesidades
ni con las mismas circunstancias y la
mujer específicamente tiene una
situación que en algunos casos es mucho
más compleja tal vez para integrarse a
la nueva sociedad en el caso de ustedes
que cuál es la experiencia que indica la
experiencia ustedes no usted me decía
antes de comenzar la emisión de que
contrariamente a lo que uno supone
muchas veces la mujer que ustedes
conocen en su lugar de trabajo se
integra muy fácilmente es así
en sanya 20 nuevos 90 etnias diferentes
y tenemos una diversidad también de
lenguas y el idioma en español el
español es muy importante en nuestra
región somos la capital agroalimentaria
del este de canadá y justamente las
mujeres no viven en dificultad mayor
porque hay tanto trabajo y posibilidades
de emprender que las vemos si al
principio son sacrificadas porque
siempre le toca ese rol podemos decir a
la mujer que al principio ella se puede
quedar cuidando a los niños y viendo
para tenerlo de las guarderías que es
una realidad que vivimos aquí en quebec
cualquier origen étnico es la mujer que
se queda pero al principio es difícil
unos un mes dos meses y después de una
vez que ya está la gente establecida le
podría decir que a nivel profesional
vemos mujeres emprendedoras
profesionistas que logran muy bien su
camino ya hemos hablado en ciertas
ocasiones en su emisión de una enfermera
pero ahora tengo el ejemplo de una
contadora que al principio ya llegó y
fue voluntaria con nosotros para
de dominar el idioma poderse integrar
bien y ella empezó con nosotros como
voluntaria después fue a trabajar como
contadora en una granja familiar porque
somos 1400 granjas existen en sanya sem
ella fue y como era familiar la familia
le ayudó justamente a integrar la
contabilidad porque hay unas prácticas
diferentes a veces en cada país y ella
se integró también que después de sueño
de maternidad actualmente acaba de
encontrar un súper buen empleo como
contadora en la matriz de all email que
está en sanya sign como contadora para
hacer la paga de las fanb ordial que
está en el norte de quebec porque el
email tiene más o menos 22 fábricas a
través de canadá y más en quebec y ella
ahora la que la contrató le dijo oye
justamente su experiencia es bonita
porque ella como hablaba español iban a
contratar guatemaltecos que van a llegar
a esas granjas en el norte de quebec le
dijeron estábamos a alguien que hablara
español o sea que además que ella hizo
su camino poco a poco logró por tener el
idioma español tener un empleo a la
altura de sus competencias es una
integración magnífica y emprendedora
tenemos otra colombiana que logró poner
mar agua café que ganó el premio
monterrey y de la emprendedora de la
empresa emprendedora y acaban de también
tener un subsidio actualmente para hacer
la torrefacción del café en las regiones
han ya sean o sea las mujeres si viven
dificultades como todo inmigrante pero
llega a la situación de los pequeños
cuando están muy chicos de la guardería
yo le diría no es más difícil un poquito
más tardado pero yo creo que como la
mujer tiene esa garra de también
quererse integrar vemos mujeres
emprendedoras y profesionistas que están
a la altura de cualquier esposo y ya no
podemos hablar como antes yo tengo ya
más de 37 años en canadá antes y veíamos
que la mujer estaba muy rezagada ahora
le puede decir con todo el empleo que
hay la mujer encuentra su nivel y cómo
es luchona
una integración no puedo decir que hay
gran dificultad es bueno ciertas mujeres
que son analfabetas cuando vienen de
ciertos países como áfrica mismo a veces
américas latinas son analfabetas es más
difícil pero aún ahí hay fábricas que
las contratan si van a la alfabetización
porque aquí también hay analfabetos y si
van a la alfabetización y medios
desenvuelven con el francés no van a
tener problema tampoco perfecto
y acotar a lo que decía ana luisa que
tuve la oportunidad de entrevistar
justamente a lorena menezes de marihuana
café y es una chica joven emprendedora
es ella ha creado una industria
prácticamente ahí en sainthia centro y
estamos viendo como tu bien los señalaba
que las mujeres están saliendo de ese
papel y ese rol tradicional que se les
había de alguna forma asignado en el
proceso de inmigración porque venimos de
sociedades en las que
ese era el papel que desempeñaba pero
aquí bueno ya ya se está rompiendo los
esquemas y hay mujeres como lorena
menezes entre otras no de marayhuaca fe
que están sobresaliendo y creando empleo
además se crearon su empleo y están
generando empleo en la región y como
estamos hablando de empleo y estamos
hablando de integración y milena
pertenece a un centro que trabaja en uno
de sus ejes temáticos precisamente con
el tema del empleo pues la oferta
laboral más frecuente que existe en la
región de ustedes para los jóvenes que
llegan a ese lugar yo puedo decir que es
la más frecuente es como soldadores hay
una grande
la necesidad de soldadores hay
muchísimas ofertas de empleo de
metalurgia en en granjas también hay
porque tenemos hermosos semirural
también tenemos necesidades de la parte
administrativa también hay bastantes
trabajos como ingenieros mecánicos metal
mecánicos ingenieros industriales
ingenieros no solamente trabajo manual
exactamente hay muchísima oferta
nosotros en este momento tenemos 120
ofertas de empleo no cubiertas o
cubiertas y cuál es la principal
soldadores sólo necesitamos soldadores
de mano de obra calificada también
tenemos ingeniería ingeniería ingeniería
se necesita bastante y alguien que esté
interesado que resida ya aquí en canadá
pero que no esté en la zona de
influencia de ustedes y escuche esta
emisión y se entere ahora de que hay 120
puestos vacantes que es lo que tiene que
hacer aquí tienes que ser puede
entrar a la página de carrefour de un
ejemplo a nicole es ya más acá en esta
página tenemos las ofertas de empleo
específicamente por área y pueden
postular directamente a ser una
candidatura espontánea o se pueden
contactar conmigo a inmigración a
comercial sigue
bueno pues vamos agregar todas maneras
toda esa información en nuestro sitio en
internet la gente que llega a la región
de ustedes corre el riesgo como las
grandes ciudades de llegar con un título
universitario y tener que hacer tareas
que no son para las que se preparó yo
digo que las oportunidades están dadas y
si hay una gran dificultad pero más que
todos a nivel podemos decir que un
médico no es no es tan fácil de volver a
entrar a su mismo trabajo hay ciertas
profesiones que son difíciles no puedo
decir que todas pero por ejemplo si
hablo de mi caso
ha sido fácil mi implicación de
integración y conseguir un trabajo mismo
si mi francés no estaba me trizado
entonces exacto dominado lo que pasa
exactamente ya como que mi francés está
mejorando entonces pienso más en francés
que en español pero empiezo a revolver
español francés inglés eso es una locura
pero pero es eso es eso hay
oportunidades y yo digo a la gente sea
positivo
piense positivo si hay dificultades pero
todo se plato se organiza con el tiempo
como yo digo yo no tenía un francés
excelente pero como decía las mujeres
berracas con perro en que hay hombres
también verracos que quieren salir
adelante y todos se organizan vivir en
regiones mucho más fácil sep el arriendo
es más económico el acceso a comprar una
casa
por ejemplo en nicolette usted puede
conseguir una casa de 180.000 dólares
eso no lo consiguió esté acá en montreal
los costos absolutamente todo es más
económico el desplazamiento no hay
tráfico entonces vivir en regiones es
mucho mejor para una familia para un
niño
más aire libre es más fresco no
realmente vivir la región es mucho mejor
perfecto pablo es perfecto y viene
región en la medida en el caso de los
inmigrantes en que puedan tener acceso
justamente al trabajo porque en ese
momento se les dificulta
la vida
y en la región tiene que desplazarse
para ir a trabajar en álava pero de
todas formas y es importante es un
proceso de cada uno tiene su proceso
migratorio y para todos es diferente
puede que para unos en un año ya están
en trabajo para otros en cinco años pero
todo se organizan con el tiempo
tranquilamente queda una discusión con
jon era y si teníamos teníamos una vamos
si eran inmigrantes recién llegados o
que está terminantemente prohibido nos
dijo poner desde el salón divisar la
palabra
es un asunto de sensibilización más que
todo de la sociedad de aquí porque es el
desconocimiento de cultura de muchas
cosas
y por eso infundimos nosotros ese ese
objetivo junto con los alcaldes del
territorio en que se prohibiera a decir
inmigrante es una sensibilización y es
hombre eso ha funcionado
eso ya no decimos inmigrantes porque eso
justifica mucho al individuo como tal
entonces decimos el recién llegado
el colombiano o el mexicano o el
argentino
el connacional diferente eso ha
funcionado de verdad que sí
y lo hemos implantado a nivel
empresarial a nivel comunitario
indudablemente a nivel político de a
nivel social aunque perfecto y me parece
excelente
a nivel semántico no de que se haya
prohibido pero ustedes ofrecen servicios
de acogida a recién llegados cuáles son
los desafíos de ofrecer esos servicios a
ver el recién llegado eso depende de
todos saben muy bien
el proceso que hay desde la persona de
que están en otro de sus país de origen
cuando llega aquí y cuando llega aquí
tenemos que hacer esa función también de
transportarlo a una segunda etapa de
inmigración 7 migratorio de
establecimiento entonces empieza desde
una base que la base desde cero cero es
aquí estoy no sé nada
ana luisa tiene la experiencia también
de venir a visitar los centros de
acogida
igual nosotros lo hacemos y son personas
que están así aquí esto no sé nada no sé
ni dónde estoy parado nada no sabe ni
llenar un formulario también las
personas que nos trae mucha formación
ahí donde nosotros brillamos es ahí
donde los organismos como los nuestros
brillan y dicen venga para acá usted me
interesa ese es el perfil venga para acá
que yo tengo cómo ayudarlos y lo
ayudamos a hacer todo todo es todo ellos
descansa mente se inscriben aquí
hablemos de una categoría la categoría
de moda actualmente realiza la categoría
demanda de asilo de solicitantes de
asilo es la categoría de moda eso no se
veía antes hace 34 años no se veía mucho
como ahora no ahora es el apogeo y eso
pues lo hago en el actual primer
ministro federal destruido entonces esa
categoría indudablemente la que más se
trabaja es la que le está dando las
opciones a las empresas y el mismo
gobierno le da la opción tenga su
permiso de trabajo vaya ubíquese y ahí
donde nosotros estamos y somos clave
para integrarlos
vamos a comenzar a redondear porque
aunque parezca mentira ya no nos queda
tanto tiempo para esta emisión el tiempo
se va acabando la hora y no tenemos
el teléfono entonces yo no digo yo
quería preguntarle a
analista puede ser emprendimiento en
base a la experiencia ustedes cuál es el
emprendimiento más frecuente y exitoso
si es que nos puede dar un ejemplo y qué
emprendimiento podría ser llevado a cabo
y aún no ha sido iniciado
por ejemplo lo que han hecho
como de financiar a un emprendedor de la
diversidad cultural por ejemplo bueno yo
he visto a bastante negocios por ejemplo
de comida típica no
[Música]
de brasil por ejemplo qué bueno que
decide hacer estas bolitas de chocolate
riquísimos o bueno alguien de de
latinoamérica que va a cocinar [ __ ]
o realmente hacer comida típica de bueno
que viene de su país lo que la gente
conoce realmente porque bueno cuando
lanzas tu empresa realmente es
importante tener conocimiento en lo que
vas a hacer y para corregir en todo caso
un poco la pregunta que emprendimiento
recomendarías no intentar
muy buena pregunta sería difícil de
llevar a cabo que cree que sería difícil
de financiar de aprobar bueno yo diría
de empezar pequeño porque si una persona
empieza y necesita un montón de montón
de dinero puede ser difícil después
bueno porque claro hay intereses
entonces de empezar pequeño y es algo de
lo cual hablamos también en inglés se
llama instagram entonces bueno si de
solamente pedir un poco de dinero para
empezar y después más y más y más
pablo y gabriel vamos a comenzar a
redondear como decía mi colega luis
laborda el tiempo pasa como agua entre
los dedos allá en tu región
y con tu experiencia con el centro para
la inmigración en región
y digamos como hablábamos ahorita
analiza decía algunas historias de éxito
de emprende de emprendimiento en tu
región
personas inmigrantes que estén contentos
satisfechos y que haya tengan éxito en
lo que quieren claro perdón claro que sí
como decíamos no apunta todavía la la
multiculturalidad pero nosotros nos
dimos a la tarea también de identificar
algunas familias que ya están
establecidas por allá y cómo estamos
nosotros obviamente promoviendo todo lo
que es a nivel agrícola
tenemos presencia también en los
mercados y retomando un poco también de
nuestros servicios también fomentamos la
gente de comenzar empresas no porque es
una realidad también que hay que motivar
a la gente de hacer empresas para crear
también oportunidades de empleo y
estamos como picando piedras no nuestra
en nuestra región para todo eso entonces
para regresar también a la pregunta
estamos nosotros motivando a la gente
también desde hacer como mestizajes no
de digamos o hagamos pupusas pero
hagamos la con carne local de bisonte
que encontramos en la región no yo
sí exactamente
hagamos tacos de carne de orina lo
llevamos ayer a llamar eso él está
abierta como por decir estamos haciendo
cosas así innovadoras también para no
quedar un ejemplo también nosotros
estamos promoviendo productos locales
que nosotros mismos transformamos
hacemos salsa picante pero bueno metemos
de fresa en la receta lo metemos
betabel entonces hay gente que sí que
está por ahí hemos identificado a
algunas familias una familia
guatemalteca una señora que hace jabones
hay por ahí una persona de bulgaria que
está produciendo miel y bueno por ahí
está una que otra familia más que están
integrados y que están tratando
precisamente de sobresalir no de de
tomar esa como rareza o si podemos
decirles a éste
características diferentes que
que puede también hacerse como un plus
no en la región ya entiendo que hay que
hacer muy creativo si alguna forma louis
ana luisa sintéticamente a la mujer que
esté ya aquí o esté a punto de arribar a
quebec y esté buscando su lugar aquí
cuál sigue el argumento que utilizaría
para traerlas a nyasango a la región de
influencia de que ustedes tener la
actitud para lograr lo que se propone
como objetivo y al venir hacia acá y
también estará abierta a ver que una
pequeñas ciudades tiene bastantes
factores que le permiten de poner paso
por paso lograrlo yo no diría que
nosotros es 1 a 5 años yo le diría son
meses a veces semanas pues es muy grato
el empleo cuando dentro de esos factores
está el justamente venir si me están
oyendo fuera de canadá a empezar el
francés aunque sea mínimo en línea el
ministerio ofrece cursos en línea
empezar con el idioma francés empezar
también a ver cómo hacer un currículum
vitae
adaptado al aquí y ver también cuál es
lo que ella quiere hacer llegando sea
pueden desde antes de emigrar empezar a
prospectar y ver por medio de internet
hay una facilidad ahora de poder
conectarse también con nosotros nosotros
no hacemos las cosas por ellos los
guiamos somos guías porque me gusta
decir que la persona que hace su
integración
nosotros acompañamos y guiamos y las
personas
puedes ir en sanya zen tenemos
emprendedores electromecánicos
informáticos hernando y
a mí ya me empezaron un sistema de
numeración para las empresas que acaban
de recibir financiamiento de la mercè de
más qt o sea aquí es una tierra de
oportunidades han yacen es una región
cercana a montreal y la mujer como le
digo tanto como el hombre y no importa
el origen pueden lograr un lugar de vida
y de trabajo ideal para integrarse y
vivir durablemente en franca face nos
queda muy poco tiempo entonces quería ir
cerrando esta mesa y no sin antes
presentarle a ricardo aseveró que se
acercó gentilmente a compartir esta
emisión con nosotros aseveró trabaja
para calificación quebec que lleva a
cabo el trabajo de reconocimiento de
estudios de títulos como es exactamente
[Música]
y gente me aceptaron muchas gracias
entonces en calificación que ven
nosotros somos la puerta de entrada en
todo lo que tiene que ver con la
reconocimiento de diplomas y de la
experiencia de quién que ve que tenemos
tenemos
dos consejeros en nuestras oficinas y
tenemos el portal el sitio internet
calificación el plural que bwin com
donde todos los pedales personas
interesadas pueden encontrar todas pero
prácticamente toda la información y creo
que tiene que ver con una profesional
particular en este momento hay más de
500 fichas disponibles en el portal
después de que hemos hemos desarrollado
y escrito desde agosto de 2018 en un
momento en que lo pusimos en línea
quiero decir que el calificación quebec
es una iniciativa desde el gobierno de
quebec
estamos hace ya más de dos años
trabajando en el desarrollo del sitio
internet y en el en la redacción de
fichas en nuestra oficina aconsejamos a
la gente ayudamos a preparar una
estrategia ayudamos a nosotros tenemos
costumbre decir a poner sobre la mesa
todas las posibilidades en lo que tiene
que ver con reconocimiento de diplomas y
de la experiencia muy bien pablo como
decimos habitualmente el tiempo se nos
escurre entre las manos no tenemos mucho
más
solamente agradecerles a nuestros
invitados que de haber aceptado la
invitación el haber estado aquí el
compartir con nosotros el trabajo que
hacen para asegurar desde distintas
facetas la integración del inmigrante
del recién llegado para que no se enojen
obviamente para decirles a todos
recordarles a todos el mensaje entonces
que creo que surge de esta mesa que es
en ocasiones hay posibilidades hay
recursos hay una provincia y un país que
están abiertos a recibir como
habitualmente inmigrantes que siguen
llegando en gran número cada año one aio
la tradición de canadá y señor que es
los inmigrantes forman parte de una de
un sector muy importante de la población
de este país aproximadamente el 22 por
ciento en todo caso más del 20 por
ciento de la población es inmigrante y
que más allá de los problemas que se
puedan presentar en integración de cada
uno
no es imposible convertirse en un
ciudadano más y en tener éxito aquí
lamentablemente ricardo no tengo más
tiempo así que no te puedo dar la
palabra nuevamente pero les agradezco a
todos una vez más su presencia aquí y
los invitamos a compartir nuevamente con
nosotros una nueva emisión de canadá en
las américas del café la semana próxima
pablo muchas gracias también los
invitamos a que visiten nuestro sitio y
ahí van a encontrar la información de
todas las personas que han participado
en esta mesa hoy y les deseo mucho éxito
y el programa va a estar como es
habitual en nuestro sitio de internet a
partir de mañana viernes y durante todo
el fin de semana gracias a todos los que
nos siguieron en vivo y hasta la semana
próxima gracias
[Música]